Christopher go ahead I was gonna go on
about my way but gary said he wanted to
challenge me to an IQ test all right you
want to come down here anywhere any time
I'll give you a test right now you
couldn't pass right chemical test
there's ten people on the race Gary you
overtake the last person what position
are you in there's ten people in a race
I over take the last person what
position are you in well I would think
it's nice but it clearly can't be the
right I answer it yeah how can you
overtake the last person you're the last
person right then I get the [ __ ] out of
you dummy I can keep going okay good I
want to give you three words and I want
to tell me what the words are okay you
ready sure okay first word MC do n ALDS
say that again slowly AC AC do n no you
said MC oh I said AC MC MC keep up so
make it sounds like McDonald's but I
didn't hear all the letters so I'm like
okay you got that one right
next word m AC do you clas it sounds
like MacDougall's correct okay last one
it's the trick point ma c-h-i Kenny H I
and E H I and E okay quickly behind it's
machine you're [ __ ] in it win time
that's that IQ that's just [ __ ] dumb
trick
[Laughter]
you